bonsoir hier soir à berlin-est 4000
jeunes s'étaient rassemblés aux abords
du mur pour écouter le groupe rock
genesis qui se produisait côté ouest à
l'occasion des fêtes du 750e
anniversaire de la ville un attroupement
que les forces de l'ordre est allemandes
ont tenté de disperser
en vain pascal richard depuis longtemps
la musique à sauter les frontières et
jamais les barbelés n'ont pu arrêter le
rock
de l'autre côté du mur aussi genesis et
david bowie sont des idoles à l'occasion
des concerts donnés devant le reichstag
à quelques mètres seulement du mur mais
côté berlin ouest
les jeunes allemands de l'est faute de
pouvoir y assister entendez bien hier
soir s'en mettre plein les oreilles
l'inconvénient pour eux c'est que cette
musique n'a pas adouci les moeurs des
policiers est allemand loin s'en faut
non content d'établir une seconde
frontières à 700 mètres du mur
c'est ici que s'arrête le territoire de
la rda ce soir at-il été répondu aux
jeunes gens les forces de sécurité ont à
leur tour sorti leurs instruments à
coups de matraque
plus d'une cinquantaine de personnes ont
été interpellées un technicien de la
télévision reste allemande a été quant à
lui sérieusement tabassé des heures qui
montre à l'évidence que la
libéralisation tant désiré par
gorbatchev demeure encore un voeu pieux
de ce côté ci du mur et dans la nuit
berlinoise l'appel au secours au maître
du kremlin avait hier soir quelque chose
de presque irréel